[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de cómo lograr que las
medidas contra la pandemia no impacten
negativamente a la economía y es que las
restricciones derivadas de la emergencia
sanitaria por la pandemia del
coronavirus han hecho que muchos
negocios no puedan seguir funcionando de
la misma manera derivando en muchas
regiones en una crisis económica es por
ello que nos acompaña de eduardo iturbe
presidente de la cámara de comercio
pachuca muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros señor iturbe en qué manera se
puede afrontar la disposición oficial
del cierre generalizado y la consecuente
parálisis económica
a partir del mes de enero de este año se
dio el segundo cierre generalizado del
comercio y de los servicios
en el estado en mi estado de hidalgo y
eso trajo como consecuencia pues que
entremos en un proceso de parálisis
económica que ha sido pues profundamente
nos ha afectado de manera muy fuerte en
virtud de que a diferencia del primer
momento en donde se ocurrió este cierre
generalizado pues ahora no tenemos
ahorros hemos consumido los recursos que
habíamos preparado en torno a esta
planificación y nos encontramos en una
situación donde ya se visualiza el
desempleo la moral está muy baja y los
comercios no encuentran una alternativa
para poder salir adelante
y hacer frente a sus responsabilidades
económicas o al soporte de la nómina con
sus empleados sí y cuál es el futuro de
las economías emergentes como las que
hay aquí en la región en américa latina'
en el caso de las economías emergentes
en donde gran parte de nuestro comercio
es a través de nuestro vecino del norte
estamos pues entusiasmados con los
cambios políticos que se han dado en
eeuu esperamos que exista una
recomposición en materia de la dinámica
económica que trabajamos y también
esperamos que el asunto de la movilidad
por el asunto de la pandemia pues no
tenga las mismas repercusiones en un
sentido económico de materias primas y
pues de divisas
qué pueden hacer los gobiernos en sus
políticas económicas respecto a esta
emergencia sanitaria cuáles son las
alternativas para evitar el colapso del
señor eduardo iturbe
y la única manera en la cual nosotros
vemos posible que se evite el colapso de
las economías es que nos permitan
trabajar en este momento a diferencia de
cuando inició la pandemia estamos
equipados contamos con dispositivos
cubrebocas con la sana distancia con el
empleo de gel con el adecuado aseo de
manos con las caretas con un sinfín de
instrumentos incluyendo las pruebas
diagnóstico que nos permiten operar de
una manera más segura y más confiable
no podemos tener cierres generalizados
que paralizan la economía adicional a
ello el gobierno federal y los gobiernos
locales ya no tienen la posibilidad de
darnos apoyos o estímulos económicos
de acuerdo a las políticas que ellos
emplean lo cual nos pone en una
situación muy difícil prácticamente lo
que queremos es salir adelante haciendo
lo que nosotros sabemos hacer que es
trabajar pues muchas gracias eduardo
iturbe él es presidente de la cámara
nacional de comercio pachuca y a ustedes
muchas gracias por su compañía les
recordamos que la información no se
detiene con actualizaciones constantes
aquí en nuestra señal televisiva y
también información al momento en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom que
disfrute de su día siga con nosotros y
también cuídense y mucho del cobi 19
[Música]